countryes living in two different
realities it's wild when you talk to
Republicans and you talk to Democrats
about January 6 you get two different
versions of reality you talk to
Republicans about January 6 they're like
what's the big deal you know it's the
party that got out of hand
what it
happens you've never stolen a Podium it
happens dude you never been to a party
had a couple too many trules things got
weird you know like black Brown band was
supposed to be there he didn't show up
people got
upset you never got too drunk and wanted
to zip tie a sender
happens you talk to a Democrat about
January 6 they're like it was the
Holocaust